I have a function here defined as x
squared minus 5x plus 6 and what I want
us to think about is what other forms we
can write this function in if we say
wanted to find the zeros of this
function if we wanted to figure out
where does this function intersect the x
axis what form would we put this in and
then another form for maybe finding out
what's the minimum value of this we see
that we have a positive coefficient on
the x squared term this is going to be
an upward-opening parabola but what's
the minimum point of this or even better
what's the vertex of this parabola right
over here so if the function looks
something like this we could find we
could use one form of the function to
figure out where does it intersect the x
axis so where does it intersect the x
axis and maybe we can manipulate it to
get another form to figure out what's
the minimum point what's this point
right over here of this function I don't
even know if the function looks like
this so I encourage you to pause this
video and try to manipulate this into
those two different forms so let's work
on it
so in order to find the roots the
easiest thing I could think of doing is
trying to factor this funk or factor
this quadratic expression which is being
used to define this function so we could
think about well let's think of two
numbers whose product whose product is
positive 6 and whose sum and whose sum
is negative 5 so since their product is
positive we know that they have the same
sign and if they have the same sign but
we get to a negative value that means
they most they both must be negative so
let's see negative 2 times negative 3 is
positive 6 negative 2 plus negative 3 is
negative 5 so we could rewrite f of X
and so let me write it this way we could
write f of X as being equal to X minus 2
times X minus 3 now how does this help
us find the zeros well in what in what
situations is this right hand expression
is this expression on the right hand
going to be equal to 0 what's the
product of these two expressions if
either one of these is equal to 0 0
times anything is 0 0 times anything
else is 0 so this whole thing is going
to be 0 if X minus 2 is equal to 0
or X minus three is equal to zero add
two to both sides of this equation you
get X is equal to two or X is equal X is
equal to three so those are the two
zeros for this for this function I guess
you could say and we could already think
about it a little bit in terms of
graphing it so if we wanted to so let's
try to graph this thing so this is x
equals one this is x equals 2 this is x
equals 3 right over there so that's our
x-axis that you could say is our y is
equal to f of x axis and we're seeing
that we intersect we intersect both here
and here when X is equal to 2 this f of
X is equal to 0 when X is equal to 3 f
of X is equal to 0 and you could
substitute each either of these values
into the original expression you'll see
it's going to get you to 0 because that
is the same thing as that now what about
the vertex what forum could rewrite this
original thing in order to pick out the
vertex well we're already a little
familiar with completing the square and
when you put it in kind of a in that
form or when you complete the square
with this expression that seems to be a
pretty good way of thinking about what
the minimum value of this function is so
let's just do that right over here
so I'm just going to rewrite it so we
get f of X is equal to x squared minus
5x and I'm just going to throw the plus
6 right over here and I'm giving myself
some real estate because what I need to
do what I want to think about doing is
adding and subtracting the same value so
I'm going to add it here I'm going to
subtract it there and I can do that
because then I've just added 0 I haven't
changed the value of this right-hand
side but I want to do that so that this
part that I've underlined or in this
magenta color so this part right over
here is a perfect square and we've done
this multiple times when we've completed
the square I encourage you to watch
those videos if you need a little bit of
a review on it but the general idea is
this is going to be a perfect square if
we take if we take this coefficient
right over here we take negative 5 we
take half of that which is negative 5
halves
and we square it so we could write this
as plus negative what's negative
five-halves squared so I could write
this negative five-halves squared
well if we square a negative number it's
just going to be a positive so it's
going to be the same thing as 5 halves
squared 5 squared is 25 2 squared is 4
so this is going to be plus 25 over 4
plus 25 over 4 now once again if we want
this equality to be true we either have
to add the same thing to both sides or
if we're just operating on one side if
we added it to that side we could just
subtract it from that side and we
haven't changed the total value on that
side so we added 25 over 4 and we
subtracted 25 over 4 so what is this
part right over here what does this
become the part that I've underlined in
magenta well this is going to be the
whole reason why we engineered it in
this way is so that this could be X
minus 5 over 2 squared and I encourage
you to verify this and we go into more
detail about why that you know taking
half the coefficient here and then
squaring it adding it there and
subtracting there why that works we do
that in the completing the square videos
but these two things you can verify that
they are equivalent so that's that part
and now we just have to simplify 6 minus
25 over 4 so what is so 6 could be
re-written as 24 over 4 24 over 4 minus
25 over 4 is negative 1/4 so minus minus
1/4 just like that so we could we've
rewritten our original function as f of
X is equal to X minus five-halves
squared minus 1/4 now why is this why is
this form interesting well one way to
think about it is this part is always
going to be non-negative the minimum
value of this part in magenta is going
to be 0 because why because we're
squaring this thing if you're taking
something like this and we're just
dealing with real numbers and you're
squaring it you're not going to be able
to get a negative value at the minimum
value this is going to be 0 and then or
or and then it obviously could be
positive values as well so if we want to
think about when does this thing
hit its minimum value well it hits its
minimum value when you're squaring zero
and when are you squaring zero
well you're squaring zero when X minus
five-halves is equal to 0 or when X is
equal to 5 halves if you just want to
add 5 halves to both sides of that
equation so this thing hits its minimum
value when X is equal to 5 halves and
then what is y or what is fun f of X
when X is equal to 5 halves F of 5
halves and once again you could use any
of those forms to evaluate 5 halves but
it's really easy in this form when X is
equal to 5 halves this term right over
here becomes 0 0 squared 0 you're just
left with negative 1/4 you're just left
with negative 1/4 so another way to
think about it is our vertex is at the
point so we could say our vertex is at
the point x equals 5 halves y equals
negative 1/4 so x equals 5 halves that's
the same thing as 2 & 1/2 so x equals 5
halves and y is equal to negative 1/4 so
if that is negative 1 1/4 would be
something like that so that right over
there is a vertex that is the point make
it clear that's the point 5 halves comma
negative 1/4 negative 1/4 and what's
cool is we've just used this form to
figure out the minimum point to figure
out the vertex in this case and then we
can use the roots to kind of as two
other points to get a rough sketch of
what this parabola rough sketch of what
this parabola will actually will
actually look like so the interesting or
I guess the takeaway from this video is
just to realize that we can rewrite this
in different forms depending on what
we're trying to what we're trying to
understand about this function